5 horas de fila para una hora de oxígeno
diariamente cientos de personas llegan a
esta calle en ciudad de méxico para
comprar oxígeno vital para sus seres
queridos con hobby 19 la mayoría debe
esperar para recargar un tanque que a
veces solo dura una hora
estos tanques hitos no son suficientes
entonces con esto
teníamos que llenarlos de 4 a 5 veces al
día y noche
entonces corren le y se acababa uno y
aun a alguien se tenía que venir a
formar y el otro porque aquí es el único
lugar que que son 24 horas de ahí en
fuera en ningún otro lado consigues
llevamos aproximadamente aquí hoy un
compañerito de tres a cuatro días todos
los días aquí todo el tiempo hasta en la
madrugada por el tipo de pacientes que
tenemos mal que son varios no son uno
sino son varios entonces tenemos que
estar aquí rellenando día y noche
nuestros tanques de oxígeno
con 9 millones de habitantes ciudad de
mexico está en alerta máxima desde el 18
de diciembre los hospitales tienen una
ocupación del 90 por ciento por la
rapidez con que 'el hobbit' 19 se ha
propagado en la población
en días anteriores el gobierno aseguró
que hay suficiente suministro de oxígeno
clínico sin embargo la realidad en las
calles es otra cómo la demanda supera la
oferta los distribuidores cobran hasta
cuatro veces más por una recarga el
precio varía entre 160 a 990 dólares el
tanque de oxígeno a esto se suma a los
precios en el mercado ilegal que se
abastece con tanque robados en empresas
u hospitales y que venden a precios
exorbitantes actualmente más de 1,7
millones de personas se han contagiado
en méxico y más de 149.000 han perdido
la batalla contra el jove 19